[Music]  Ellen DeGeneres debuts a hilarious food  to celebrate keeping up with the  kardashians milestone season on friday's  episode the TV host brought back her  alter ego the sick sister Carla in honor  of the show's 10-year anniversary  [Music]  there we go over here you're too tall  for this okay where's Carla mom she's  always late  Ellen even had a special gift for the  reality TV family since news broke of  their bombshell baby news since it looks  like every other day there's an another  Kardashian that's getting pregnant I got  them something the best part is when the  baby outgrows that they can recycle it  and make like six dollars and fifty  cents or something  [Music]